I remember watching outdoor games all the time uh
as a kid I thought that it was just the coolest
thing I was always fascinated by uh the jerseys
the teams would wear and sort of the old school
inspired gear the goalies would have never
know what kind of weather it's going to be I
think it's it's something that's fun just brings
you back to you know your childhood when you're
just skiing on outdoor ranks I grew up playing
outside so uh it's nice to to get back to your
roots and uh it's a pretty cool event to play
in my favorite part was walking out before the
game doing the anthem having the planes fly over
all the smoke fire stuff going on I think there's
nothing that's ever going to top that in in the
realm of a hockey rank or hockey game the the
games have been awesome obviously the first one we
played was in Dallas and um at the cotton ball and
just that whole experience was really cool just
seeing that many people packed in for hockey in
in the South you know it's pretty rare and then
the one we we had in in Nashville against Tampa
Bay was awesome too at the at the Titan Stadium
and just being the home team was a lot more fun
just have all your fans on your side and uh was
able to score a goal there in the third which
was really cool just being able to celebrate with
all with yeah triple the amount of people that we
normally have was was pretty awesome playing the
big house in Ann Arbor and I think 108,000 people
in attendance two original six teams it was cold
snowing so it was uh it really took me back to uh
to being a kid and that's something uh you that's
that's one of those games that are up there on
my list the Winter Classic um in Washington DC
at Nats Park was pretty cool uh I think it was
like my second year so it was definitely like
a welcoming to the league uh moment just to see
that many people cheering you on and I think we
scored the the game-winning goal in the last in
the last minute or so so that was uh that was a
fun fun night I remember watching the the Rangers
game at uh outdoor Yankee Stadium that was uh
just a cool cool atmosphere I mean all of them
are special in their own ways but uh that one I
think stuck out to me for me I'll never forget
playing at Yankee Stadium and playing at night
it was awfully cold but uh uh other that being
really cold the conditions were fantastic I think
the atmosphere of Islander Ranger uh fans was was
unbelievable it was so clear and just playing
under the stars and and obviously at such a
historic ballpark um one of the the biggest and
best sports franchises in the world um it was one
of those uh one of those games and moments for me
that just didn't want it ever to end I think it
was Boston Philadelphia I think it was at Fenway
Park obviously being from Boston it was one that
we remembered and actually got a a Winter Classic
Bruins Jersey for Christmas that year so that was
pretty sweet it was customized with with my
own name on the back and everything so going
to Fenway we were young and you got away with a
little bit more when you you know you're kid so
like we were able to like kind of run around and
switch seats and uh go up we kind of like snuck up
on the green monster and watch the game a little
bit from up there so so that was a pretty cool
experience I went to the game in Vancouver I was
fortunate enough to go to that which was awesome
I mean those are those are incredible those
outdoor games I think there's nothing really
nothing better immediately comes to my mind is
the Jonathan T's goal came across the Blue Line
in the offensive zone dangled someone went five
Bowl I think and it barely squeaked in I remember
watching the first ever winner classic it was
you know really cool and snow coming down it
was awesome to watch the first one was one that I
think everyone talks about favorite outdoor memory
would be Sid scoring that uh the Shuckle with the
snow coming down chance to win the game um he's
kind of just P pushing the puck along uh through
the snow I think every Canadian hockey player can
relate to that being on the outdoor rink when it
gets a little snowy it's uh it's tough to handle
but um Sid obviously puts a great move on and
and a big moment and uh and scores a big goal
you know watching Sydney Crosby go from scoring
in just piles of snow in the shootouts going five
PA Ryan Miller and then going in the locker
room just trying to get hot chocolate and uh
it just seemed like he was a kid again and and
that's kind of what hockey's all about [Music]